[Music]
a bill that could
abolish the death penalty here in nevada
is moving its way through the state
legislature
and now a las vegas woman is pushing
back after her daughter's horrific
murder nearly 10 years ago
sasha loftis shares her message to
lawmakers
alyssa otramba's mother says she's been
fighting for justice since 2011.
now she wants everyone to understand how
hard it is
for families like hers grief is a lot
like chronic pain
and it's it's always there
nearly 10 years after her daughter's
murder jennifer otremba describes how
her entire world
has changed you never expect to leave
your house with your child laying on the
floor doing homework
to you know what they found
fifteen-year-old alyssa otremba was
walking home in 2011
when she was abducted sexually assaulted
and stabbed more than 80 times
her body was then burned and left just a
few hundred feet from her northwest
valley home
will my mistakes have caused javier
righetti was found guilty of capital
murder and sentenced to death in 2017.
now jennifer is fighting to keep that
sentence on the table
after the nevada assembly voted to
abolish the death penalty
during this year's legislative session
death by execution
has failed in nevada similar bills were
introduced in 2017
and 2019 but ab 395
is the only one that's gotten this far i
was just a normal mom
raising my children and someone that
i don't know came in and took one that's
why
jennifer hopes her story encourages
lawmakers to reconsider
and understand the importance of this
kind of closure
he didn't consider alyssa's life that
day so why should we consider his
sasha loftis 8 news now
now ab 395 would need to pass on the
senate floor
and then go to governor sissellac's desk
to be signed into law
governor sisilak has said he's mostly
opposed to capital punishment
but that he does have a hard time with
the complete abolishment
of the death penalty